taking their first steps as free men
their relief is clear moments earlier
Reuters reporters while lone and jaws -
who were released from prison the
journalists jailed after in covering a
rahega massacre are finally going home
they're really happy and excited to see
our family their Collies I don't know
what to say
we're very exciting after more than 500
days in jail they can finally hug their
families free of handcuffs this is the
first time this father can hold his baby
at home while owned was in prison when
his daughter was born as the family
celebrated today's surprise presidential
pardon so too did the colleagues who
flew tirelessly for their release we are
enormous ly pleased that Myanmar has
released our courageous reporters why
alone and ciaossu
since their arrest 511 days ago they've
become symbols of the importance of
press freedom around the world
we welcome their return
[Applause]
the reporters were convicted of breaking
the Official Secrets Act after exposing
the murders of ten ringing during a
military crackdown there toured at least
38 journalists that have been detained
since anseong Suchi came to power
film director minting goggle ji was
jailed for criticizing the military
Naaman Sui got a seven year sentence for
violating the country's Sedition law in
a Facebook post it has been way or with
you human rights activists say critics
are being deliberately silenced by
jailing journalists who export atrocity
and serious abuses committed by the
Myanmar military it sent a chilling
effect it has created a climate of fear
in Myanmar making the military
untouchable and now the government is
cell is following that footstep by
making itself an institution that is
above and beyond criticism because these
men celebrate their release some hope
further press freedoms will follow but
democracy and Myanmar has been stalling
and the Rahim des Massacre is still
largely unpunished
Siobhan Robbins Sky News